the Somali pirates coming ashore is a
change in tactics and it's deeply
worrying the safety of two foreigners
kidnapped from Kenya's north coast is
the number one priority but more is at
stake Murray did you old and disabled
was an easy target a beach hut was no
challenge for the armed gang her partner
still traumatized by the ordeal thought
about fighting back and we guess hard as
it would lay down and
thank you
Moffat's man
this guy with me DC to me to bed in here
stopped because I went in to cut one of
them cause me any and it is the one who
should have me when I was passing into
his window this is the second abduction
of a foreigner in less than a month 58
year old David Tebbutt was shot dead as
he tried to protect his wife Judith she
was taken hostage and a pirate gang
claims to be holding her inside Somalia
the British government then warned about
travel to the region but has since
revised its guidance now we are seeing
possibly copycat kidnappings taking
place and that's very alarming that's
why we have said within 150 kilometers
of the Somali border now people have to
be very conscious of that the risk area
has more than doubled the 90 mile zone
includes the lahmu archipelago but
Malindi and Mombasa key tourist
destinations are well outside for now at
least almost a hundred and sixty-five
thousand Britain's visited Kenya back in
2009 and what makes the country such a
popular location is the ability to
combine a big game safari with a trip to
the coast if you take that away suddenly
Kenya isn't such a desirable destination
but the Pirates have proven to be both
persistent and resourceful better
protection of ships sailing through the
Gulf of Aden saw the bandits extend
their range far into the Indian Ocean
the move onto land has been forced in
part by better maritime policing but if
the easy foreign targets move further
south along Kenya's coast then there's
nothing to stop the Pirates doing the
same